bonjour bonsoir à toutes et à tous
ici argot rock et il est très tard il
est même très tôt il est 5 heures du
matin a carrément je sors d'un game j'ai
vu vers minuit le film s'est terminé
vers trois heures 3 heures 20 le temps
qui avec les crédits etc
waouh je sois il ya tellement de choses
à dire je vous cache pas que j'ai pris
plein de petites notes pour faire cette
vidéo parce que ça va être
je me perdre sinon il ya trop de choses
c'est ma tête elle est comme ça bien
évidemment cette vidéo sera 100% spoil
donc si vous n'avez pas vu le film je
vous encourage à quitter cette vidéo et
à revenir une fois que vous aurez vu le
film je pensais vous faire une petite
critique sans spoil
mais ça me ressemble pas et je peux pas
parler du film sans devoir spoil surtout
que là ya tellement de choses à dire
donc vous êtes prévenus bien comment
sont directement avec l'analyse mon avis
sur le film décortique ont eu un petit
peu donc on commence avec des choses
assez prévisible c'est tout ce qui a été
montré dans le trailer les dix vingt
premières minutes sont très très rapide
même trop rapide et on en vient à la
question de voilà on va retrouver la
noce on sait où il est grâce à nebula
comme l'avait supposé l'ami aeros f
notamment et du coup ils retrouvent la
noce est thanos passe complètement au
ridicule en termes de puissance
puisqu'il se fait complètement arrachée
mais c'était ça correspond bien en fait
un l'instant parce que thanos à gagner
thanos a accompli ce qu'ils voulaient
faire il n'a plus rien à faire
maintenant à part mener une vie
tranquille et s'il meurt bah tant pis sa
mission sera accomplie
c'est clairement ce à cette scène donc
comme je l'avais supposé personnellement
c'est justement que thanos a terminé sa
quête donc les pierres si elle existe
encore servent seulement de convoitises
comme ils l'affirment dans
le film et c'est un gros risque pour
justement les avengers qui vont vouloir
effectuer un snap inversée du coup un
peu comme dans les comics donc
effectivement thanos a pas pris de
risque et il a détruit toutes les
pierres mais on devait revenir là dessus
parce que ça à quelques conséquences
évidemment anthony n'était pas tant que
ça au bord de la mort on l'a très vite
compris avec la suite dé nouveau trailer
tout les trailer sont vraiment très vite
amené comme c'était prévu en fête les
vingt premières minutes du film mais il
y en a quand même qui voit quand même
quelques scènes tout au long du film qui
était dans les trailer enfin bref les
vingt premières minutes sont assez
prévisibles puis on est projeté cinq ans
après l'élément perturbateur évidemment
c'est ce bon vieux scotland qui a réussi
à revenir d'un vraiment un coup de
chance énorme avec le vieil or à qui
marche sur la machine quantique les
vingt premières minutes ont été balayés
par les traits leurs fins les traits
c'était tout ce qu'il y avait dans les
thrillers là on commence à rentrer
vraiment dans le concret à partir des
cinq ans après et scotland a une idée il
pense que le voyage dans le temps est
possible le voyage dans le temps c'est
je pense la plus vieille théorie que
j'ai fait sur le mc depuis une finity
war et je suis content qu'un qu'elle y
soit techniquement vrai donc évidemment
il ya plein de choses ultra surprenantes
notamment le fait que tony et d'une
fille
on savait on pensait que ça pourrait
arriver et c'est le cas du coup il a une
fille et
et on comprend qu'il doute sur le fait
de vouloir inverser le snap
mais tony reste tony est évidemment
c'était au budget qu'ils allaient se
prêter au jeu et trouver la solution de
l'équation pour justement réussir le
voyage dans le temps on parle quand même
de tony stark s'est clairement l'avenger
ce le plus intelligent du mc eu
nous sommes d'ailleurs sur un film qui
tourne beaucoup autour de tony alors
qu'on ne s'y attendait pas vraiment on
savait qu'ils seraient vraiment
important tony notamment par rapport au
plan de doctor strange mais on va y
revenir mais c'est clair que c'était pas
teese est comme ça à la base c'était
surtout captain marvel virait scène post
générique d'une infiniti war est en
hausse avec le fameux thanos will return
in game enfin voila on arrive à quelque
chose que j'ai vraiment mais vraiment
apprécié du coup c'est la théorie du
voyage en temps qui s'est confirmé mais
surtout la logique qui a été amené il
est vrai que l'agent de tence a
plusieurs significations ça à plusieurs
interprétations
c'est un bordel pas possible pour suivre
comment ça fonctionne et là je trouve
que c'était vraiment hyper bien
maîtrisée et que ça a été extrêmement
bien amené effectivement si tu modifies
le passé ça va pas changer le présent
enfin comme dans retour vers le futur où
la focus comme l'expliquent hyper bien
banner et c'est une logique que je
trouve impeccable c'est que si vous
retournez dans le passé du coup le passé
devient votre futur puisque vous allez
dans le passé et du coup le présent où
vous étiez devient le passé et ça je
trouve que c'est une logique implacable
et qui devrait fonctionner réellement
pour le voyage dans le temps et ça j'ai
vraiment apprécié parce que du coup ça a
balayé toutes les conséquences qu'on
pouvait imaginer sur le voyage dans le
temps c'est que ce qui a été fait a été
fait on peut pas y revenir c'est fini à
part le snap
évidemment le snap c'était comme si tout
les toute l'humanité tous les 50 pour
son univers été mis sur le banc de
touche et
et pouvait revenir à un moment ou un
autre mais ceux qui sont morts or snap
c'est fini on peut pas revenir sur ces
morts donc ça c'est vraiment un très
gros point fort que j'ai apprécié dans
le film c'est que c'est cette logique
elle est vraiment implacable et je suis
content que ces termes n'est pas ce que
je trouve qu'on on la voit pas assez
souvent dans le cinéma
ensuite on en vient à l'élément
principal et [ __ ] c'est ouf parce que
j'ai fait une vidéo en tire sur sa et le
voir en vrai arrivée dans le film ça m'a
fait une sensation vraiment trop bizarre
c'est la théorie bah justement des pires
d'infinité c'est que justement sur tous
les héros qui reste ça a été soulignée
un film c'est que au moins une personne
sait où se trouvent les pierre d'infini
nebula avec vomir et la pierre de l'âme
requête avec la pierre du pouvoir sur
morag tort avec les terres bref que des
trucs comme ça et je suis trop content
d'avoir mis le doigt dessus
vous allez penser que je me jette des
fleurs mais en vrai je ressens une
certaine satisfaction je la voulais donc
du coup on comprend très vite tout le
film va nous amener
et du coup on va voyager dans le temps
sans avoir des conséquences du coup et
des modifications du passé puisque le
but est de modifier le présent on reste
dans la même réalité il va pas y avoir
une autre branche de créer et justement
ça a été soulignée avec l'ancien c'est
que si on ramène toutes les pierres du
coup il y aura pas une nouvelle branche
qui va être créée dans la timeline donc
on reste vraiment dans la même dame
lines ce qui simplifie énormément la
chose pour la fin de la phase iii parce
que sinon c'est vrai qu on aurait ça
aurait créé un bordel pas possible pour
le début de la phase 4 et serait projeté
trop vite ce que marvel pourrait prévoir
avec les dimensions les branches et à
mme line etc
les univers parallèles on en passe et
des meilleures je vous avoue que c'est
un peu confus dans mon esprit il a
tellement de choses à traiter on va
essayer de parler d' un max de choses et
on va essayer de se concentrer un peu
plus sur certains personnages aussi
j'aimerais notamment parlé de
l'importance de nébuleux nebula est un
personnage que qui est vraiment très
secondaire dans les films va se cacher
et ici elle possède une importance assez
capitale au final le personnage va
évoluer d'un coup notamment grâce à tony
key
lui transmettre certaines valeurs etc et
notamment les conséquences du plan de
thanos et où elle va se rendre compte
qu'elle était juste un pion important de
nebula me rappelle énormément les comics
ou je ne sais plus si c'est elle qui
vraiment met fin à thanos qui tue tanoh
dans les comics mais je sais qu'elle
elle porte le grand moment et fait
beaucoup de mal à nos justement avec le
gant donc je trouvais qu'on revenait un
petit peu à ça mais sous une autre forme
comme je vous le rappelle le mc lui
s'inspire des comics mais pioche par ci
par là des informations et crée son
propre univers donc l'importance de la
bulle a été vraiment très agréable et je
pense que ça va amener de nouvelles
choses au personnage et qui va
certainement évoluer
nous allons arriver par contre sur une
petite déception je vous la vous c'est
la transformation de banner je suis un
poil des succès était vraiment mais trop
rapide genre voit banner l'image après
ses professeurs hulk
voilà c'est un moment que c'était hors
is et on savait que ça allait arriver
forcément le professeur hulk mais ça
aurait été bien de voir l'évolution
comment il est devenu professeur hulk je
trouve que ça a été trop expédié mais
clairement ces mêmes même pas expédier
si on est passé de ça à ça en une image
et ça j'avoue que c'est une petite
déception alors évidemment il ya aussi
le claquement de doigts donc ça c'est
c'était pas mal théorisé il est vrai que
hulk était potentiellement le seul à
pouvoir tenir le choc du claquement de
doigts et certainement tort mais bon
tant envers venir un je pense que vous
savez pourquoi donc c'était très
légitime que ça soit sûrs qu'ils fassent
ce snap inversée et c'était à peu près
ce que je prévoyais
personnellement même si je n'ai pas
beaucoup parlé en vidéo et ça je suis je
suis ravi de le voir parce que c'est
fait du bien de voir banner enfin
propulsé au rang qu'ils méritent et
évolue on a un très bon personnage très
équilibré et très puissant à sa manière
du coup j'ai trouvé ça excellent le fait
de par exemple voir banner parler avec
l'ancien et échanger philosophiquement
sur les timeline le voyage dans le temps
et c'est alors qu'il est dans le corps
de hulk justement en parlant de l'ancien
j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup aimé le
rapprochement qu'elle fait avec doctor
strange le fait que banner est 50 avance
par rapport docteur strange et qu'il
serait le meilleur des sorciers suprême
ceci est clairement une référence aux
comics où on sait que ou le seul ancien
savait que strange allait prendre sa
place bien avant qu'il naisse et c'était
cool de l'amener je trouve
parlons maintenant du sacrifice de
natacha j'avoue que j'ai vu assez tard
le sacrifice de natacha car je ne
m'attendais pas j'avais oublié
complètement les conséquences de vomir
et de la pierre de l'âme et du goût le
fait que ce soit au cas il ya une
attache a été obligé que ça soit l'un
des deux qui sacrifie évidemment pour
avoir la pierre il n'y avait pas d'autre
solution et jusqu'à la fin on s'est
vraiment passé qui des deux qui va se
sacrifier pour final je préfère que ça
soit natacha c'est vrai que hockey au
final il a une famille enfin le
personnage commence à évoluer en quelque
sorte il est très utile dans in game il
faut vraiment de grosses valeurs plus
content qu'il soit affirmé qu'ils
deviennent un meilleur personnage parce
que je trouvais qu'il commençait à
s'essouffler justement c'est le problème
de natacha natacha commençait vraiment à
s'essouffler de ouf
natacha là aucune particularité à part
les arts martiaux et pour la phase iv je
la voyais pas du tout évolué à part
prendre un rôle assez secondaire dans le
shield donc c'était soit une mourrait
pour moi soit elle prenait sa retraite
techniquement en gros elle travaillerait
aux côtés de nick fury
donc je trouve que c'est une belle fin
pour le personnage pour moi fallait
qu'elle s'arrête un moment ou un autre
voilà je sais pas trop quoi dire de plus
c'est une belle feinte pour natacha ça
en valait la peine
passons maintenant à une seconde petite
déception que je vous avais parlé
justement dans mes attentes ma grosse
crainte qui au final c'est confirmé
c'est le rôle de thanos effectivement du
coup voyage dans le temps nous sommes
sur un panneau ce qui vient du passé un
thanos qui n'a pas eu l'expérience
l'histoire et tout ce qui s'est passé
dans l'infiniti voir en fait c'est un
thanos qui vient à peine de posséder une
seule pierre il n'a pas posséder les six
pierres il n'a pas fait le claquement de
doigts et du coup ce que nous sommes sur
une sorte de thanos un petit peu moins
philosophe un petit peu moins nature
mature pardon qui a moins évolué on va
dire il n'a pas subi par exemple la
perte de gamme aura les conséquences de
son claquement de doigts et c est
justement nous sommes sur un thanos du
coup très brutal un thanos beaucoup
moins philosophe et qui souhaite juste
faire le mal du coup et malheureusement
ça c'est une petite déception
bien qu'il ait eu des échanges etc
thanos n'a pas apporté cette petite
touche de philosophie de la vie de la
philosophie de sa mission par rapport à
une finity voir mais ce qui est normal
du coup puisque nous sommes sur un an
tan aux plus anciens qui étaient
beaucoup plus brutale donc du coup c'est
logique mais je suis un peu déçu par
rapport à ça en revanche le combat
ultime est exactement comme je le rêvais
c'était qu' il y ait pas du coup une
première partie mais et une seconde
partie du cool mais cette première
partie est exactement comme je voulais
c'est à dire
captain tony et or contre thanos et ça
c'était vraiment ce que je voulais
absolument voir les trois piliers des
avengers les trois plus vieux avengers
du mc hugh techniquement parlant on va
dire les trois papas on va dire ça y est
c'est plus simple combattre le titan et
ça franchement c
c'était un pur régal clermont bat
justement les trois visa ventures
parlement un petit peu de steve
bon là on va passer du tout où on va
parler de tout ce qui concerne steve
steve
vraiment une [ __ ] d'évolution il ya
tellement de choses à dire sur lui on
pourrait faire une vidéo en tire sur lui
je pense que ça pourrait arriver
notamment avec le marteau de thor un on
va pas se le cacher j'avoue que je n'ai
pas d'explications concrètes sur comment
c'est possible que captain puisse
maîtriser le mieux venir le marteau de
thor faire des éclairs avec etc
je pense que les éclairs c'est dû au
marteau mais pourquoi il le manipule
aussi aisément et avec une telle
puissance comme thor et il tient même
stormbreaker à un moment je suis
incapable de trop l'expliquer il était
clair que c'était déjà amené un petit
peu dans age of hull tron ou captain
avait réussi un petit peu à le bouger
mais j'avoue que je n'ai pas
d'explications concrètes va falloir que
je réfléchisse à la question sur
pourquoi et comment il a pu
maîtriser autant mjolnir peut-être que
la puissance de thor a régressé par
rapport à mieux venir et du coup captain
serait plus digne de le porter on va
dire
ou peut-être que c'est quelque chose en
soi peut-être que quelque chose en
captain a changé a évolué il a une
mentalité qui a changé peut-être et il
en est digne je suis incapable de vous
dire est spécialement comment on y
reviendra
en tout cas c'est vraiment la meilleure
fin qui pouvait avoir pour captain
america et je suis mais comblé par
rapport à toute l'histoire qui l'a vu
dans le film captain america est le plus
vieux avengers techniquement parlant
puisque c'est le premier véritable
avengers on va dire sans compter les
carroll c'est le premier on va dire
vraiment du projet avengers et le
personnage commençait à vieillir
il vient de 1945 environ voilà c'est
plus du tout la même époque il a fait
son évolution il a apporté beaucoup et
il était clair que le personnage
commençait à s'essouffler et allait
s'éteindre à un moment ou un autre
la mort était le plus probable et marvel
lui a donné la fin qu'il méritait
clairement captain toujours droit dans
ses bottes a eu la faim qu'ils méritent
il retourne dans le passé et fait sa vie
avec peggy jusqu'à même vieillir
alors justement par contre ça c'est un
petit point que je n'arrive pas trop à
comprendre c'est que comment capter n'a
pu réussir à vivre parce que justement
la logique qui a été amené dans endgame
c'est que si tu retournes dans le passé
le passé devient ton futur on ne peut
pas modifier le passé
le problème c'est que captain america il
a déjà le sérum du super-soldat il est
déjà un surhomme il peut pas vieillir
techniquement il est un surhomme et
voilà c'est il doit faire avec
cependant il retourne dans le passé il
revient il est vieux du coup c'est
[Musique]
j'avoue que c'est j'arrive pas trop à
comprendre
à moins qu'ils aient échangé sa place
avec rousseau sereine où je pense que
c'est une bonne théorie que je tiens
c'est qu'il est échangé sa place avec le
stif de l'époque steve du coup a fait sa
vie normale et lui il allait avec peggy
dans son époque et du coup c'est le
style du passé qu'on voit vieux en fait
je pas si vous arrivez à me suivre le
stif du présent du futur on va dire et
retourner dans le passé et vivre avec
peggy autant qu'il peut et le vieux
steve que nous voyons c'est le celui du
passé qui a fait sa vie du coup
puisqu'il ne revient pas directement sur
le portail
mais il y assis sur un banc et ses jeux
faciles vous comprenez ma pensée je
pense que ça c'est une bonne théorie je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais en
fait je vois pas trop d'autres
explications
en tout cas faut qu'on va devenir le
nouveau captain america certains vont
être certainement déçus puisque c'était
normalement 2 qui dans les comics qui
donnait de nouveau captain on va dire
mais c'est pas plus mal que ce soit faux
combat ce que bucky c'est comme captain
je pense qu'il en a marre je pense les
îles pareil mais pas à son époque qui
ils fatiguent et ses enfants personnage
s'essoufflent un petit peu aussi je
pense alors qu'il faut qu'on il est
jeune il est prêt à en découdre et
cetera je pense que ça lui a bien de
devenir le nouveau captain c'était assez
attendu et ça va propulser le personnage
clairement cependant tort à leurs torts
subis un gros nerf dans endgame c'est
assez incroyable d'ailleurs et je pense
que généraliser une explication par
rapport àça tort à la fin définitive war
est clairement au vert tchité 1 il est
présenté comme le héros ultime qui peut
vaincre la noce même avec les six
pierres cantat n'ose dire son rayon est
que lui il arrive avec sa hache il est
clairement ouvertes jt et détruit
l'oeuvre l'armée de thanos à lui tout
seul et je pense qu'ils lui ont fait le
même traitement que banner dans infinity
ward parce que justement banner étaient
au vert tchité aussi à sa façon
puisqu'il pouvait tenir le gant et
résister au pouvoir des pierres tort du
coup était peut-être trop puissants et
ils ont voulu
le nerf comme ils ont fait avec banner
dans infinity voir je vois vraiment
cette seule explication
en parlant de thor justement je suppose
que vous avez tous vu le petit placement
pour fortnight je pense que ça va faire
grincer des dents certains mais au final
ce n'est pas trop choquant si vous vous
rappelez bien et vite j'ai eu un gros
partenariat entre fortnight epic games
du coup et infinity ward avec marvel où
il y avait un mode de jeu où nous
pouvions jouer la noce et c'est déjà
parent revenu à un nouveau mode de jeu
encore entre fortnight et avengers ou
dans forte taille vous pouvez avoir le
bouclier de captain america enfin ça
reste assez liés ils ont l'air d'être
assez bon partenaire donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas étonnant de le voir dans le
film mais c'est voilà j'ai l'impression
qu'ils gèrent pas tant que ça les
placements de produits dans le mc eu
c'était un peu le même problème avec
captain marvel avec le nerf j'aï trouvé
j'en ai jamais reparlé mais je trouvais
que c'était un petit peu mal à mener
mais bon ça reste un détail ça ne change
rien au film techniquement ça m'a pas
gêné tant que ça font aussi que
j'aimerais également revenir et qui n'a
pas du tout été amenés dans le film mais
bon c'est assez implicite c'est que ma
gamme aura est morte elle est vraiment
morte et c'est fini en fait gamme aura
été dans la pierre de l'âme elle n'était
pas réellement morte elle était enfermée
dans la pierre de l'âme du au sacrifice
de thanos mais du coup thanos a détruit
les pierres au début du film et bagues à
mort a été dans les pierres a été dans
la pierre de l'âme du coup l'explosion
des pierres a fait disparaître camorra
c'est aussi simple que ça et à la fin du
coup nous sommes sur la gamme aura du
passé qui s'est rendu compte que thanos
était un fdp que c'était juste un pion
pour lui du coup là c'est la gamme aura
du passé qui va prendre la place de la
gamme aura du présent et du coup il va
essayer de la reconquérir je pense et
rebâtir ce qu'il avait bâtie avec
l'ancien camorra mais c'est vraiment
étrange du coup et ça pas été vraiment
expliqué dans le film c'est assez
particulier mais du coup la camorra du
présent est morte elle est morte c'est
voilà c'est ouf
alors évidemment vous allez me parler de
la scène ultime aussi il va être temps
d'en parler la scène pile team où tous
les héros arrive etc vous avez dit que
j'avais peur justement d'une fin un peu
à la super smash bros brawl où tous les
héros arrive et casser la gueule à la
noce mais au final je reviens sur mes
mots et ça a été franchement l'une des
meilleures scènes du film j'avais des
frissons mais toulon mais vraiment tout
le long il y avait tout doctor strange
qui a qui a tout manigancé car ils
savaient dès qu'ils reviendraient ils
savaient il a tout manigancé pour finir
justement le combat ultime et peur qui
arrive en armure tous les héros même
walkyrie etc
c'est vraiment c'était une scène
incroyable et je reviens sur mes mots au
final ça n'a pas été une fin à la super
smash bros brawl et c'était clairement
une très belle scène d'un film au départ
je pensais que ça allait être captain
marvel qu'elle est débarqué du coup avec
une armée de scroll et de cris par
exemple au final le conflit a lardé
toujours actif sur les autres planètes
du coup mes projets tomber à l'eau mais
je ne regrette pas du tout cette scène
et je les trouvais franchement très
marquante est très impressionnante
en parlant de captain marvel tiens
justement
le personnage a été assez bien utilisé
au final assez secondaire mais assez
utilisé c'est vrai que captain marvel ou
encore vraiment intégré dans les
avengers est pas vraiment encore une
avenger elle est un peu là en soutien
ces gens relais du team qu'on appelle et
sa coupe de cheveux du coup fait
clairement référence aux comics où elle
a une coupe de cheveux comme ça en fait
et c'était une belle référence je trouve
je n'ai pas grand chose à dire sur
captain marvel mais je me pose beaucoup
de questions sur la suite des événements
parce que du coup est ce que la suite de
captain marvel soit captain marvel deux
se situera encore dans le passé mais du
coup on connaîtra déjà l'avenir
ou alors est-ce que ce sera la suite
mais après
endgame mais c'est à dire qu'on passe
sous sous silence
20 20 années où captain marvel a fait
plein de choses avec les skrull écrit on
ne saura pas par six c1 est vite fait
quoi donc je ne sais pas bon enfin il
est temps je pense de parler de la mort
de tony stark et oui tony nous a quittés
et personne ne le voulait j'en avais
parlé plusieurs fois mais j'avoue que
j'ai beaucoup douté dans le sens où tony
est un peu genre le symbole marketing en
fait de marvel et des avengers
il ya tellement de jouets iron man tous
les gosses adorent iron man et c'est
vrai que je doutais par rapport du coup
à sa mort mais plutôt à une retraite
mais plus le temps passe et plus je
voyais et strange lui dire un an si je
te dis ça va pas se passer comme prévu
quand il le regarde et que ces genres
c'est le moment c'est là c'est le moment
me suis dit allez c'est bon
tony ça va être la fin tu vas faire
l'acte ultime mais tu vas y ait cet avis
et ça a été le cas et ça fait clairement
bizarre imaginer une suite sans iron man
sans tony stark
ça chamboule et franchement
j'ai été très ému de la scène de la mort
de toni surtout l'enterrement nous
voyons tous les réunit tous les gens qui
la côtoyaient qu'il a connu il y avait
même en bim qui à la base était un rival
des stark et qui détestait howard lui
même était présent et clairement c'était
vraiment une scène très très très très
émouvante
du coup black widow on s'en fout là
quidome est morte à la même période
enterrement digne de ce nom par contre
tony il a eu clairement le plus bel
enterrement qui soit
c'était vraiment une belle scène et au
final il a réussi à faire un claquement
de doigts je savais qu'il allait mourir
quand il a fait le claquement quand j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient les six pierres
monsieur y aller c'est bon il va mourir
aucun humain ne peut tenir normalement
leye le pouvoir des six pierres il a
réussi néanmoins à faire le claquement
de doigts mais il était clair qu'il
devait partir et bon sens les paroles de
peur quand il parle à tony jean mode
elle demande en gros les l'état tony
quand elle entend ce c'est un état
critique et qu'elle lui dit justement
qu'elle comprend et que maintenant il
peut se reposer
l'ouverture d'esprit de pepper le fait
qu'elle comprenne autant son fiancé
qu'elle elle sait ce qu'il fait vibrer
elle l'a pas empêché de faire ce truc du
voyage dans le temps et pourtant elle
connaissait les risques
elle savait qu'ils avaient de gros gros
risques tout comme lui c'est franchement
une scène très lourde et très très
émotive g
j'étais pas bien je voulais vous que
j'étais pas bien acheter j'étais pas
bien du tout j'étais vraiment fun
enfin quel avenir pour la suite quel
avenir pour le mc eu un an un an et un
mois mais quand théorise suresnes games
et ça y est on y est arrivé maintenant
il faut penser à l'avenir
alors ça c'est une petite déception
c'est que pour moi la phase iii devait
se terminer avec ken games mais au final
ça va se terminer et spider man alors
j'ai peut-être une explication par
rapport à ça peut-être qu'on pourrait
revenir dans une prochaine vidéo façon
je vais vous faire une vidéo qu'elle
suit quel avenir ensuite pour la phase 4
et pour le mc ou spider man va sortir
cette année je sais plus en fin d'été il
me semble un truc du genre ou en plein
milieu de l'été
ça sera la suite de l'origine story du
du jeune héros mais je pense que
malheureusement le film en fait ça va
être comme ant man et la guêpe c'est qui
va juste servir à apporter des réponses
enfin il à eelv a pas apporté les
réponses mais il va servir à conclure en
fait il va servir à montrer je pense la
reprise de la vie normale de courant
normale de tout ce qui se passe
normalement en fait la vie a repris son
cours et c est
amènera donc l'ouverture pour la phase 4
avec peut-être potentiellement un nouvel
ennemi mais je pense qu'on va encore
attendre pour le moment mais voilà il va
amener seulement le fait que la vie
reprend son cours
et du coup l'ouverture à la phase 4
puisque le film se termine là dessus et
je pense qu'on reprendra après avec les
gardiens de la galaxie 3 et dr strange 2
enfin du coup il n'y a pas de scène post
générique et je trouve que c'est pas
plus mal du coup il aurait fallu une
scène post-générique si nous étions sur
la fin de la phase iii mais du coup
puisque c'est spider man la fin de la
phase 3 je pense que c'est bien qu'il
n'y ait pas de scène post-générique le
fait d'amener une scène post générique
pour spider man après une game je pense
que ça aurait gâché le film clairement
saurait gâcher le film puisqu'on serait
retourné à une origin story peu banal on
va pas se le cacher va se lasser de
endgame le film ultime une rue jean
story ça casse un petit peu le truc donc
c'était soit ça attise la phase 4 soit
il ne fallait rien m et ils n'ont
décidément rien m en revanche il ya
quelques ans même ya quand même quelque
chose qui m'a interpellé c'est le fait
que à la fin où il ya le logo marvell
etc
on entend comme un bruit d'un forgeron
qui tape sur une épée est en train de
forger en gros et je vous avoue que je
ne sais pas du tout ce que ça veut dire
6-6 a une signification particulière où
je pense que si ça a été mis ces cui il
ya une signification
mais quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ce
c'est c'était très étrange pourquoi il
ya eu un bruit de la moitié de forgeron
si vous avez une idée en tête ou si vous
avez une autre interprétation sa troupe
j'ai rêvé je dis des conneries mais je
pense vraiment qu'il ya quelque chose
qui se cache derrière ça sinon pourquoi
elle a mené dès que c'était un bruit
pour signaler la fin clairement dû de
toute cette étape mais
je trouve ça vraiment étrange je pense
avoir tout dit je pense et j'espère jeu
je ne sais plus quoi penser quoi dire on
est clairement à une autre page une
autre phase c'est comme s'il y avait un
vide en moi genre en mode c'est fini
voilà maintenant qu'est ce que tu vas
faire c'est terminé la fim
il y aura encore des choses à dire en
vrai on va pas se le cacher moi j'ai
envie de faire vivre le mc de continuer
à vivre pour le mc eu si vous souhaitez
des vidéos particulière des vidéos
théorie c'est n'hésitez pas à me le dire
en commentaire clairement je pense qu'on
pourra revenir notamment sur personnage
de steve rogers ou encore sur l'avenir
sur captain marvel la phase iv
évidemment donc n'hésitez pas à me dire
en commentaire je vous invite également
à participer au concours sur twitter il
vous suffira juste de rt et de follow
mon compte
ce sont de beaux prix donc je vous
conseille d'aller voir ah là là je pense
que je vais faire une dépression comme
tort vu que endgame est finie [ __ ]
tony est mort natacha est morte il
fallait qu'il y ait des morts toute
façon mes deux morts marquantes quand
même de gros personnage tort rejoint les
gardiens aussi pense que ça lui va bien
sorte de rôle de vagabond je pensais
qu'il allait peut-être s'exiler refaire
un nouvel as garde
c'est ce qui a été fait dans le film
mais au final ouais c'est pas plus mal
qui rejoignent plus tôt les gardiens
surtout s'il ya en plus le la
problématique adam warlop qui risque
d'arriver je pense que dans les gardiens
de la galaxie trois déjà on al intrigue
ils vont vouloir retrouver gamme aura
qui s'est échappé l'a réintégré au
groupe la reconquérir
et en même temps il y aura la
problématique adam warlock qui a été
teasé dans les gardiens de et que tout
le monde attend depuis un moment on voit
ce qu'on sait que c'est un gros
personnage très attendus et ils vont pas
le négliger je pense souhaitant rassurer
surtout c'est james gunn qui reprend le
reprend le film donc je suis sûr que
radha morlock qui sait ce sera peut-être
même le prochain ennemi après tout adam
warlock il n'est ni bon ni mauvais mais
il est possible que le mc eu en face un
autre personnage galactus et est
également fortement possible comme
d'autres personnages comme arnaud ce but
qu'ils aient eu la manipulation du temps
des voyages dans chaque antique
peut-être que lui ça l'a réveillé tels
qu'ils ont libéré quelque chose et que
ses chronos par exemple tout est
possible il ya énormément de choses à
faire
leak semaine les quatre fantastiques
arriveront aussi un jour dans cinq ans à
peu près s'estimer il ya quand même du
très lourd qui va arriver mais je pense
qu'il va falloir prendre le temps de
digérer et attendre les prochains films
qui vont je pense pas arrivé tout de
suite je pense que spider man va arriver
et puis après ça va se calmer un petit
peu
kara bon assez la fin je pense qu'on va
arrêter c'est une vidéo je suis mort et
je pense que j'ai beaucoup parlé
si cette vidéo vous a plu je vous
conseille vraiment à mettre un groupe où
ce bleu vous pouvez vous abonner me
suivre sur twitter vous promets de faire
plein de vidéos sur engament et sa suite
[ __ ] c'est une étape est franchie
une page se tourne énorme page il va
beaucoup me manquer personnellement
vraiment il va beaucoup nous manquer
c'était vraiment un sacré personnage il
est vraiment une très belle mort je
trouve quand même bref aller voilà
s'arrêter là vous connaissez la chanson
il ya le concours sur twitter et que le
lionheart soit avec vous et à jamais et
ce quel qu'en soit le prix
[Musique]